vous êtes là
tu vois un peu d'autotune ou pas un peu
d'autotune ou pas
tu me laisses démarrer parce qu'après
c'est trop ouf allez allez
malheureusement ma voix est comme mon
sexe elle ne monte pas très longtemps
ça je suis pas si sûr et
là je vous veux tous les amis
et là tu sais que tu me fais le rêve de
monopole
[Musique]
soirée
te toucher te caresser car la fureur de
nos baisers
me fait vraiment vibrer
alors pourquoi me faire languir oui
pourquoi me retenir sois sûr que je
saurais faire baby je saurai te plaire
et tes lèvres sont sucrés comme le
nectar
[Musique]
une saveur soif qui me met en externe
mon cœur s'embrasse
ce soir je veux émerger dans le noir
bientôt encore ma belle mes lignes sans
faire des petits charnels
avant que la vie s'ach
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu me sens sorcelé quand nous sommes
dans la paix je veux quoi je veux sentir
ton corps brûlant je ne désire si y'a
d'abord laisse-moi te conquérir et
mourir de plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si tu veux le voir pour le droit
faisons-le ce soir quoi
[Musique]
que le jour se lève avant que la
l'amour ce soir tout de suite
charnelle avant que le jour se lève
avant que la nuit s'achève et
passionnément allons doucement
prenons notre corps
califosons l'amour ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur la fin quand il est monté j'ai
laissé pour pas
l'humilier donc on fait une tournée
bientôt
de Paris tu m'en parles écoute
Notre-Dame de Paris ça revient là
on va faire un concert en plus
novembre décembre janvier pour les 25
ans donc voilà
[Applaudissements]